this is my first time having Golds penis
how spicy is it that's very spicy that's
like a 15 it's a 15 this is a quarter of
a habanero just see there there's like
20 of them he's not trying to cook for
us he's trying to kill us let's go this
is really
spicy oh
my so I'm talking to Bill's camera not
Billy's
camera talking straight to the camera
yeah straight to the camera okay right
ready
all right guys we're in my city it's New
York and today we're tapping into some
of the most iconic and ubiquitous dishes
of New York City and you know if it's me
it's got to be spicy so if you think of
New York the stereotypical Foods Pizza
Bagels hot dogs but if you ask any New
Yorkers Halal and Chinese food will also
be in that category first up is my
favorite way to start the day a spicy
slice of pizza from the legendary scar
pizza then I'm meeting up with my very
good friend Andrew Zimmer and we're
going to hit up Han Dynasty Chef Han has
invited us to eat some insanely spicy
dishes and I know if anyone can handle
it it's Andrew and last but not least
they're on every other block of New York
City a halal cart this one in particular
I've been wanting to try forever because
they serve it over spicy rice my good
friend Chef Eric aapon will be joining
us so let's get to It New
York
everyone loves a hot boy this is called
a hot boy has jalapenos spicy pepperoni
and hot honey little sweet little spicy
it's all about the Free Toppings this is
very New York you know you got to have
the red chili flakes every bite has to
have a lot of chili flakes usually it's
a Parmesan but of course scars Pizza we
have the Beautiful pecino
beautiful my restaurant is around the
corner so late nights after service I
used to come over here and you know grab
a slice of scars garlic powder I don't
care how much it makes my breath smell
like whatever it's beautiful I always
smell like garlic anyway the essential
slice in New York City it's like always
nice and crispy on the bottom this is
how I survived in New York scars right
now I would say that it it kind embodies
what pizza culture is in New York City
at the
moment man that's good now this isn't
that spicy it's a good mild spice to
kick off the day this is the perfect
amount the hot honey the sweetness
Mellows out some of that spice too a
nice balance
M wow this is really good I haven't had
scars in a while m
you can see why people are
waiting you know over an hour in line
for this tastes so much better on this
tree the New York streets second slice
for you thank
you it's not not spicy it's good though
yeah best job in the world it's a
perfect breakfast pregame to really
spicy meal I'm about to have with the
Andre Zimmer let's get
it
[Music]
Andrew what's
up good to see you good to see you
thanks for meeting me one of my favorite
restaurants right same
same ready for some unapologetically
spicy Shuan food I was born ready for
some unapologetically spicy Sichuan food
finally someone's finally someone's
ready for it you know we actually never
shared a meal together uh that's not
true we just never have sat down and
shared a meal together okay fine yes
what do you like about Hond is this a is
this a regular sort of thing for you
hondy the food is very spicy and not
jokingly spicy I'm a fan a lot of the
dishes here are rated from 1 to 10 in
spicy
think very uh clear and just kind of
transparent if you're ordering something
that has a t on it obviously it's going
to be spicy so you can't complain oh
crap is that how I thought it was one 10
is the 10 is the hot one so Chef Han is
here hello Chef how are you good good to
see you's up what should we have I'm
planning on bringing out the D that's
our number one seller here also the beef
and tri that's my favorite that's 10 out
of 10 so is the spiciest we sell but we
can always always go over so kind of
like in spinal tap your speaker goes to
11 it says 10 it's pleasure you're going
to go 11 yeah all right being born and
raised in New York City and being such a
food influence and icon in our space I'm
just
curious what you feel is Iconic nework
food first of all Chinese food in New
York has has an extremely personal and
deep relationship ship for me it is the
food that I cook the most often at home
it's the food that I eat the most often
when I'm here it's the food that I seek
out the most often when I'm traveling my
family came to New York to the Lower
East Side and lived in the shle there
the the the slum so right by Chinatown
right by Chinatown and they grew up
eating Chinese food on days that they
couldn't cook for themselves so every
Sunday we ate Chinese food with my
grandmother it was a wonderful Cantonese
style food and and now I would say that
the food of Sichuan province is probably
the most dominant of all the new
restaurant openings the idea that
there's you know four or five square
blocks that is still almost extent the
way it has been for generations and has
not been bulldozed is a testament to the
way in which that neighborhood was set
up there is no city that has as many
ethnic groups in as large populations as
we have as in New York yeah and comes
the food
this is a Food City it's the greatest
Food City on planet Earth all right Chef
okay talk to us so this is the D noodles
and then it's always like spicy chili
oil yeah with a little bit of pork yep
and the beef with tripe yes and the
twice cooked pork that's one of your
favorites right yeah for me is about as
good as food gets when it's done right
there's nothing like it tell us about
the dry pod uh the dry pod is the the
one dish we use the most amount of
spices in there's like six different
spices there dry Peppers chili oil
there's fresh Peppers there's uh and
this is a 10 uh yes yeah in spice level
I guess I'm water water where do you
like
to to go with this I mean I always love
to start with the you know the
tendon
yeah perfect you get the sharpness of
of one chili it disappears down your
throat you get the smokiness of some of
the dried chilies that's extremely
balanc when it comes to heat so you have
that movement of three different ways to
interpret that chili or like how you say
that front back nose that is awesome
like tripe is one of the most delicious
things ever the Generation Now loves
spicy food that is correct how do you
feel about that anything that
incorporates change in food I think is
good you no longer have to apologize for
food food Bean spicy spice is like a six
sense like it's it's like one of the
flavor profiles in your tongue that is
necessary that's right true Sichuan
pepper corns are only a recent addition
to the United States Department of
agriculture's list of acceptable Imports
here in this country crazy so it's
relatively new thing that you even could
have true ma la it's so addictive
transformative why was it
illegal because uh when it potents it it
kills other plants around it oh it's so
potent that it kills other plants so
then why did it become legal I mean it's
kind of reminding me of like that cuz it
tastes good [__] the other plants
finally this is the 10 this is the
[Music]
10 so
fantastic
wow we're going to try the ghost chili
chicken this a special dish I brought
out for Andrew I'm a big fan of your
Bazar show I'm same type of person I
always want to try we [__] this is the
Bull's penis oh fantastic which by the
way is the best kind of penis yes yes so
in Chinese I mean not in my opinion for
for Chinese people we believe and if you
lack of something and you just eat lots
of that so this will help your dick you
know have a better dick well we will if
that was if that was possible in my
world Chef has accentuated this one with
so many different hot chilies look at
this I mean I mean don't how spicy is it
that's very spicy that's like a 15 it's
a 15 yeah well this is this is this is a
quarter of a habier just sitting there
there's like 20 of them in there I know
I'm like that's like he's not trying to
cook for us he's trying to kill us this
is my first time having Gold's penis
really yes it looks like it's my type of
uh prot protein where it's like very
gelatinous I love gelatinous Meats well
which is why I love the tendon I love to
stripe like that's my you will
flip that's very
spicy it's spicy the first thing I get
not going to
lie first thing I get is a chili yeah
and the second thing you get is chili
and the third thing you get is the
fourth thing you get is the texture of
the mhm supp be is then this fifth thing
you get is more chili It's so spicy yeah
that is spicy yeah do you know what
happened Chef came out we ordered a
couple dishes one a 10 an eight then and
we're like oh this isn't that spicy and
he just said oh okay how how about [__]
you and out and out comes that dish
that's really delicious by the way
delicious the texture is so fun
superb my tongue feels insane right now
yeah the endorphins the the chemical
release in your body from eating chilies
you either want to run from it or if
you're a real addict like me you just
keep going back for more Andrew I have a
road trip snack for
you oh God I know this is your SP your
favorite I love this that's so sweet of
you of course thank you for feeding us
fantastic thank you so much thank you I
seting for the subway ride out to
[Music]
Brooklyn
so freaking excited it's the last stop
we're in the heart of Midtown and we're
at Adele's famous halal cart check this
line out there's so many people here
right now checking out the carts but if
you see that line it's almost two blocks
long it's freaking bananas my friend
Eric aong is meeting me a true board and
race New Yorker so I had to invite him
to get some Hal with me what's going on
Esther what's up how are you thanks so
much for joining me so excit you excited
to get some Halal the last time I had
Halal was actually in New York city so
it's like almost a tradition for me this
place smells amazing and this line is
crazy did you see this line this is nuts
what's your first thought when you think
of Hal I'm coming either from the club
um like house party late night uh
probably drinks were involved and rice I
can eat rice morning noon and night I
love rice so Hal and having that base
like the spicy rice and then you can add
in like the lamb and the chicken I just
think about like late night times in New
York City even after work like coming
after work in the kitchen and just like
it's not much open hellow spots there
why not for me I crave spicy food
totally Hal is not Halal without being
spicy it's not Halal without being spicy
but then there's so many other elements
of like the creamy sauce and then like
you have some of that like fresh green
you have some of the the hot sauce and
all that as well so there's like so many
things to like keep you interested as
you're eating it's delicious I kind of
want to know what makes this place a
little bit so special like what's this
got this line going so long sorry Eric
so we're going to have to wait in line
do we
really Mo what's up hi guys what's going
on how are you good to see you this is
Mo he's the owner of a mo what's up man
how are good to meet you man nice to
meet you thanks for having us thanks for
coming we're so excited I mean you're
excited I am yeah how long have you been
here man my dad's had it since ' 83 nice
same spot same spot so you've seen like
the city change around you but you stay
the same yes I like that so8 how does it
feel having so many different cultures
people walks of life coming and trying
your food it's amazing it's amazing you
think it's a certain certain culture
that only wants to try your food like
one pet right yeah yeah I mean that's
how it started though was to feed kind
of the taxi drivers you know a lot of
the cab drivers are Muslim they couldn't
get a good Halal meal at 2: a.m. the
next thing that was open was either
McDonald's or like a pizzer right yeah
that takes me back man my dad actually
drove a Yellow Cab um in New York yeah
so like I remember all the time just
Hing in the cab with him yeah in the
city he proba was a
customer my dad was a c my dad was a
caby and we would hop in and do the same
thing late night if you mention this to
him he'll probably be like I used to go
there what's your go-to
person the mixed over rice the mixed
over rice okay which is chicken and lamb
some vegetables salad peut bread and I
like to add fries on top and fries on
top okay nice what makes Adele's unique
yours the sauce definitely the sauce
this is my recipe hands down my Dad
loved it he was like yeah let's rock
with it doing okay should we get some
rub um absolutely like yes please mix
rice are we doing yellow rice or spicy
rice we got do spicy rice we here for
spicy yeah we have to do spicy rice make
spicy rice with some veggies yes yes yes
the way you like it the way you like it
literally always always got to do it the
way you know that is amaz one it smells
so good over here so good it's like
intoxicating it almost brings me back
it's like a memory like a sensory kind
of like memory type of thing oh I love
the way he's setting us up right now I
see all the sauces so he does like four
different sauces he like a white then
there's a green there's a barbecue
there's a hot sauce and then he put like
the french fries on top that's unique
too oh gosh thank you I don't know about
Esther's P but you go thank you
oh
[Music]
oh yeah mhm it like hits the spot
immediately yes right like was wasting
no time it's like immediate flavor bomb
it's like that Halal flavor very
quintessential yes you get a clear
understanding of every bite e the creamy
the hot you know exactly what you're
eating when you get into
it and the meat itself is really
delicious like really really really good
so nice above all I think it's seasoned
like spot on it seasoned so well so
perfectly and it's juicy M and this is
the spicy rice so the color of it right
and the rice itself even without the
sauce or yeah it's it's just so good the
rice is definitely spicier than a
regular yellow rice um but it has like
so much flavor so much flavor it's a
spicy dish but you go back to the white
sauce just for a little bit of relief
come back and then I go right back to
the spice
M what's the green sauce yeah what do
you got the green sauce is Jalapeno
cilantro vinegar oh spicy spicy M yes
please almost like a vinegarette then
yeah yeah okay o I got the sweats got
the sweats I got the sweats this the
[Music]
sweats yo where's this B that changes it
yo oh my God I love that that's wildly
good it's a different like Lev of spice
it's a fresh [__] cilantro cilantro oh
my God I see why people are so addicted
to this I see why people line up it's a
New York City cheat code over here yeah
oh my God this is the best ha I've ever
had yeah I would say safely hand sound
safely yeah seriously or just because
I'm standing I'll turn around I'll walk
away no it's really good it's really no
it really I could see why it went viral
you're getting everyone obviously from
all walks of life coming through and
like yo this is legit so I think like
cow food especially this right here man
it's just tried and
true thank you so much Mo thank you so
much thank you guys for coming hope you
liked it we didn't have to wait you got
the hottest spot in town M at this point
so they say I've heard that a lot as
well if hanging out with you means that
I get to skip the line wherever I go to
New York then we need to do this try
some of the best of the best that's why
I was like Eric he love us yo it is
[__] bomb
I knew it I freaking knew it I was like
this is the one that I think Tik Tok is
not exaggerating some people tend to
overcook uhhuh penis to the point where
it's just falling apart there's no
texture to it right you like it quite
chewy like that I love
that yeah that's spicy but it's like
nice it's like it's nice I like it I
pain is pleasure we've learned so much
about you Esther
[Music]
choy
hey guys it's Esther from heat eaters
thanks for watching please like And
subscribe and for more episodes click
here